कि नमस्कार जर्मन साहित्य हिंदी में के
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है इसमें
42वें एपिसोड्स में हमने बहुत सारे जर्मन
की ग्रामेटिकल कंसेप्ट सीखें अभी नेक्स्ट
3 एपिसोड इसमें हम जीवन का एक सर्वेक्षण
स्ट्रक्चर देखने वाले हैं और जो टिप्स
मुझे और मेरे स्टूडेंट्स को यूज़फुल हुए
वह भी हम सीखने वाले हैं तो मैंने खुद जो
अपना जर्मन है वह गए थे से सीखा है और
मेरे जो स्टूडेंट्स है जिन गुर्जरों
एग्जाम दिए हैं और को अच्छे मार्क्स भी
मिले हैं वह सब व्हाट्सएप देने होते हैं
इसलिए अभी मैं जो बात करूंगा वह रिश्ते के
बारे में करूंगा बट गिवन इन जनरल
यूनिवर्सल तो बाकी जगह भी बेबी वह बाकी
एग्जाम्स में भी वह सिमिलरली होगा
अच्छा ठीक है और दूसरी चीज जो है कि बाबा
हमने यह जो बेसिक स्ट्रक्चर क्या होता है
एकदम का स्ट्रक्चर एवं ने टू बी वन क्या
होता है और बेसिक को इतिहास पिक्चर क्या
होता है वह उन्हें अपने एग्जामिनेशन
स्ट्रक्चरल टिप्स एपिसोड 221 में देखा है
अगर आपने वापिस ओर नहीं देखा है तो देखकर
आइए तो आपको यह बेसिक साइंस पेपर होंगे और
फिर सामने वाला आपको का आगे का जो आपको
इजीली आएगा तो वहां से हमने देखा था कि
वक्त चार पार्ट होते हैं कौन से लेजर आयरन
स्क्रबिंग स्पेशली तो यहां पर थोड़ा सा यह
डिफरेंस है एवं और जीवन में कि बाबा वह सब
मिला के पासिंग था यहां पर मॉड्यूलर पास
है मतलब चारों इसमें अलग पास होना पड़ेगा
आपको 60% मिनिमम आने पढेंगे उसका फायदा
दूसरा भी है आप इनको अलग-अलग मॉड्यूल वॉइस
उनके एग्जाम देख ही सकते हो ओके और को
सबसे पहले समझ लो कि b1 क्या है तो जीवन
के बाद आपसे एक स्पष्ट किया है कि वह आप
कि आपको आपको और जर्मनी में कहीं भी गए एक
जर्मन स्पीकिंग कंट्रीज में आपने तो अपने
आप को हैंडल कर सकते हो जो रिटर्न
इंस्ट्रक्शंस है या कहीं पर अगर
लाउडस्पीकर पर कुछ चल रहा है तो आप समझ कर
उसको यू यू कैन अंडरस्टैंड थे बेसिक
इनफार्मेशन और उस पर क्लिक कर सकते हो
अपने विचार जो है अपने जो सिंपल टॉपिक पर
आप बात कर सकते हो सिंपली और अपने
एक्सपीरियंस शेयर कर सकते हो इस बेसिकली
नोटिस भी वन और जो एग्जाम पैटर्न है वह
उसी से रिलेटेड है तो उसके बेसिकली जैसे
मैंने चार पार्ट है उसमें इंस्पिरेशन और
इस रिबन है उस पर हम एक सिगरेट वीडियो
बनाने वाले हैं क्योंकि उसकी मार्किंग
सिस्टम थोड़ी सी अलग है उसके पास हम
एक्सेप्ट वीडियो बनाएंगे लेसनर यह जो है
वह एवं लोहे जैसी टूल एक बेसिक फॉर्मेट से
ही रहता है तो आज हम वह दोनों देखेंगे कि
उसका फॉर्मेट कैसे होते हैं और उसके लिए
क्या ट्रिक जरूरी है वह हम देखेंगे
को सबसे पहले से शुरू करते हैं तो लहसुन
जो है न गुड टोटल होता है अत इस मास्क जब
आप आंसर शीट या फिर निमाड़ क्षेत्र में
देखोगे तो उसको 3.33 से मल्टिप्लाई करके
हम डेट ऑफ बिर्थ मिलेंगे बट बेसिकली थर्टी
मार्क्स का वह पेपर होता है आप स्क्रीन पर
दिख रहा होगा कि इसके टोटल पांच पार्ट
होते हैं पार्लर और एक दैनिक एक है वह
समझाता हूं कि वन टू और फाइनल फर्स्ट
सेकंड थर्ड फाइव यह जो बेसिकली है वह
बेसिकली अ आपके जो हमने एवं में देखा था
वैसे पैसेज दिया होगा और उस पर आंसर लिखने
हैं वह कौन से पैसेंजर हम बाद में देखेंगे
बट बेसिकली वेरी सिमिलर तो Total 6 मार के
लिए पैसे इसके नीचे आंसर सा को लिखने जो
नंबर 3 है वह बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग है कि आपको
साथ सिचुएशन लिए होंगे और 10
एडवर्टाइजमेंट दिए होंगे और आप को जोड़ना
है तो मैच के फॉलोइंग हिस मेलोडियस कि हम
देखेंगे वह डिटेल हैं और फोर्थ जो है वह
मेरा फेवरेट है
कि मैं आपको कोई थीम दी होगी और उस पर साथ
लोगों ने अपने साथ ओपन है लिखें आपको
बोलना है कि वह आपकी स्किन व हथीन की साइड
है या नहीं बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग है हम डिटेल
में देखेंगे बट बेसिक फॉर्मेट इस सिंपल तो
एक हड़प आर्ट फॉर्म जाकर देखते हो पहला
पार्ट है उसमें जनरल लिए पर्सनल मैटर होता
है कि मेल ईमेल या ब्लॉग होता है और उस पर
आपको छह क्वेश्चन सकते हैं आपको सिर्फ वह
पढ़ना है और उस पर छह क्वेश्चन के आंसर
देने यहां पर राइट ओर रॉन्ग ई लव स्टेशन
फॉर इंच की कौन सी लिखना है आपको तो इसमें
इस प्लेटफॉर्म ड्राइड दूसरी चीज बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट होती है क्या सीटों तक भी जाओ
प्रॉब्लम Jio SIM रहेगी मतलब पहले
क्वेश्चन का आंसर पहले ही उनका लास्ट
क्वेश्चन का आंसर लास्ट में हो गए से आईडी
नहीं होंगे तो वह भी आपको हेल्प करेगा
उसके बाद फिर आप पर आपको पहले क्वेश्चन
पढ़ने हैं आपको पहले अगर आप पढ़ नोट्स
बनाने हैं यू कैन डू इट एस यू थिंक बोडी
अकबरुद्दीन ओवैसी कभी नहीं होगा कि फर्स्ट
क्वेश्चन एंड में है और फिर का आंसर
शुरुआत में तो पहले छह मार्क एकदम सिंपल
है एक सिंपल मेय ब्लॉक टाइम होगा उस पर
आपको आंसर लिखने ठीक है सेकंड जो है उसके
सेकेंड के 282 भी होता है दो न्यूज़ होते
हैं तो न्यूज आर्टिकल जाते छोटे-छोटे और
उस पर आपको फिर तीन क्वेश्चन होते हैं
एबीसी वाले ओके और न्यूज आर्टिकल जनरली
day-to-day लाइफ पर होते हैं कि बाबा मतलब
काम के बदले रैंक ऐसा कोई भी टॉपिक होगा
और उस पर आपको तीन क्वेश्चन 3 मिनट तक ऐसे
दो बार हो गए छह मन सिंपल है राइट और
शिफ्ट जो है फिर वह जनरली होगा कि आपको
कुछ तो मतलब है कि आप कहीं फिटनेस
स्टूडियो में गए हो या हॉस्पिटल में गए हो
तो वहां पर आपको जो इंस्पेक्शन उपाय
स्विमिंग पूल पर गए हुए इंस्ट्रक्शन लिखे
होंगे वह इंफेक्शन या फिर अपने घर पर कोई
टेबल लाया वह को जोड़ना है तो
क्वेश्चन रहेंगे तो जनरल फिजिशियन टाइम
क्योंकि ऐसा कोई उल्टा ब्रिटेन स्पेशल तो
देगा ने राइट के अंदर स्विमिंग पूल पर
जाना है तो जाओ रुपए तो हमारी जिम्मेदारी
नहीं है कोई नहीं बोलेगा तो जंगरोधी आगे
यह सिलसिला तो यह को है 6 416 मार्क हो गए
समझे सिंपल
कि पृथक जो है थर्ड में क्या होता है कि
आपको ना सिचुएशन होते हैं कि मतलब एक तो
वहीं आप समझ में कौन से जॉब करोगे टाइम या
फिर अ फैन से बुक्स रीड करोगे ऐसे टाइप
180 धार्मिक होता है और फिर साथ लोग होते
हैं और साथ लोगों को कुछ स्पेसिफिक चीज
चाहिए सुपारी एग्जांपल कि भई मार्च नाम का
बंद है उसको मतलब अगर अगर अपना क्रीम होगा
कि मैं छुट्टियों के जॉब्स तुम रुको भाई
जॉब भी करना है फिर उसके साथ फ्रेंच बींस
घी और कोई फैमिली है उसको जॉब तो करना है
पुरूष के साथ कंप्यूटर सीखना है तीसरा कोई
तो है जो सिर्फ क्रिकेट पर जॉब कर सकते
हैं चौथा कोई तो है कि मैं उसको फॉरेन
जाती है जॉब करने ऐसे नुस्खे सिचुएशन
होंगे और फिर नीचे 10 एडवरटाइजमेंट होंगी
उसमें से एक ऑलरेडी एग्जांपल को गया होगा
तो आपके पास न एडवर्टाइजमेंट हो गया
अटैचमेंट में फ्रेगनेट वेट करूंगा कि मैं
आओ फ्रांस में आपके काम को दूसरा अटैचमेंट
होगा हमारे होटल में काम करो
क्विट को पिकअप करना है तीसरा है कंप्यूटर
सीखो और उसके साथ कैसे कम हो तो यूनिट-2
जस्ट मेक श्योर जगह का अरोड़ा जजमेंट क्या
बोल रहा है वह तक रक्षाबंधन एडवरटाइजमेंट
और आपको इसके साथ जोड़ना है थोड़ा सा एक
क्यों मैंने क्या किया कि यह तो यह साथ है
और यह नोट है और उसमें भी यह साथ में से
किसी एक को कोई प्रोडक्ट नहीं महसूस होगा
तो उसके आगे आपको यह जीरो लिखना है तो बजे
सेपरेट थे वह आपको जब एक-एक शुरू करोगे तो
आपको समझ में आ जाएंगे जो फोन है वह मेरा
सबसे फेवरेट है उसमें क्या होता है कि
आपको यह क्रीम दी जाती है मतलब थी मतलब
क्या है कि वह सिंगल शॉट देर भी अब बहन
वीडियो की या फिर सीधे लिमिट ऑन आटो बिड
हाइवे पर जर्मनी के लिमिट होनी चाहिए
क्या-क्या शुड बी देकर बहन और टॉक्सिंस
स्टेट ऑन सिटी सेंटर ऐसे 300 होंगे और साथ
लोगों ने उस पर अपने आंसर डिग्री दी सर
लेटर टो थे एडिटर के वाहक तो उसमें वह जो
पर्सन है मुझे साथ लोग हैं वह टीम के साइड
से हैं या उसके अगेंस्ट एक नया तो यह नहीं
करना है एकदम सिंपल तो सपोर्ट अगर थीम है
कि बाबा वीडियो गेम पर बैन होना चाहिए कि
नहीं तो पहला आदमी बोलेगा अरे यार मैं तो
बिल्कुल के हाथों की वीडियो गेम पर बैन
होना चाहिए उसके कारण नई पीढ़ी का बहुत
गंदा होता है अनवांटेड बच्चा 5 सेंटेंस
उसने लिखे होंगे तो आपको क्या करना है कि
बार हां यह तो उसकी साइड से या दूसरा
बोलेगा कि वही है
तू मेरे को लगता है कि इससे कुछ फायदा
होगा आज तक के तो फिल्मों में भी इतना
सारा वायलेंस है जिसको देखना है उसको
बैलेंस देखेगा तो बैंक करके क्या मिलेगा
तो आपको ना बोलोगे मोस्ट आफ थे टाइम्स ई
डिस्टिक रोड आपको 4 5 सेंटेंस होंगे उसमें
जो इंपॉर्टेंट जो दो सेंटेंस आपको निकालने
पड़े थे कि उसमे वह बोलता है इसका तक वह
बोलेगा कि हम मेरा तो ऐसा मानना है कि यह
तो सैनिक ही नहीं बनता है या फिर या इट
मिक्स सेंस ऐसे वर्ड्स होंगी कभी-कभी जैसे
नॉर्मल नाइट में भी होता है कोई भी डालेगा
हां यह सब ठीक है कि उसमें बॉयज होता है
वह सब ठीक है पर क्या कर सकते हैं कि
जिसको जो करना है वह कर ले दो तो मेरे को
तो लगता है कि शायद नहीं होना चाहिए कि तो
एक दूसरी उंगली के लिए व्यापारी होना
पड़ेगा इन दैट वास इंटरेस्टिंग इट्स
समथिंग कि जहां पर आप अपना दिमाग लगा सकते
हो यह जस्ट अंडरस्टैंड तरह सॉफ्ट एंड से
का कोई आया नहीं लिखने साथ वृक्ष होते हैं
जो समझना है तो देखो जैसे मैंने बोला आप
इधर घनश्याम 16 मार्च के लिए क्या था कि
बाबा 65 की नीचे कि हम सर्च 7 मार्ग के
लिए मैसेंजर फॉलोइंग 7 मिनट के लिए या
नहीं ओके तो अब हम देखते हैं कि इसके लिए
व्हाट कैन यू डू इन दबंग के टिप्स क्या है
तो सबसे पहले एग्जाम से पहले एक हमने
मुकाबले में बढ़ानी पड़ेगी जितनी अच्छी वह
बदले राम द बेस्ट विशेस ओके डिलीवरी के
लिए होना इस घड़ी न आपको कोई थक वॉइस है
कि अगर आप नेट पर सर्च करोगे तो आपको
क्वालिटी की खुद की वोकैबलरी कि पीड़ित
मिलेगी वहां से आप कर सकते अपनी-अपनी
मुकाबले कि आप बढ़ा सकते हो जितना पढ़
सकते हो उतना पढ़ बाइक जब भी आप यहां पढ़
सकते हो तो बहुत सारा मटेरियल मिलेगा वहीं
कि वेबसाइट पर आप बहुत सारा मटेरियल
मिलेगा कितना आपको आदत होगी उतना अच्छा है
गौर थे के वेबसाइट पर आपको दो पेपर भी
मिलेंगे आप वह सॉल्व कर सकते हो आल्सो अगर
आपको चाहिए तो मैं जनरली दो
इस समय नहीं करता पर मेड हेयर फॉल जैसे
बुक है और मैं ज्यादा रखो मैं नहीं करूंगा
कि 10 या 12 आपको इस पॉइंट को है मैंने इस
नोट देखिए कि जंप करते हैं समझ लो पैटर्न
समझ लो उसके बाद आप अपना पंप रेशम के
अगिलिटी क्या है कितने आपकी वोकैबलरी है
उस पर डिपेंड है अभी ड्यूरिंग एक्जाम क्या
कर सकते हैं तो ड्यूरिंग यह सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट थिंग आपके पास फिर सिक्सटी
फाइव मिनिट्स है और यह पर मिनट है
तुम्हारे हाथों से आपके पास सिक्सटी फाइव
मिनिट्स है और ऑलमोस्ट 15 वर्ड्स तो हरमन
आप समझ सकोगे भी नहीं कुछ वर्ड आप केयर
लेवल के आदि की भी होंगी व्हाट यू नीड टो
अंडरस्टैंड सुच ए करेक्ट निकालने चाहिए हर
एडवर्टाइजमेंट आप आदत करेक्टली पढ़ते
बैठोगे तो नहीं होगा यू नीड टो फाइंड उठा
लेना इसमें क्या बोलते हैं यह फ्रंट में
जाकर यह करना इसमें क्या है यह अगर आप
निकालोगे ना तो वर्क होगा समझ न टाइम
मैनेजमेंट स्पष्ट है दूसरा यू हैव टो
डिसाइड कि मैं आपको किस राशि नाम से जाना
है मुझे खुद को पसंद है और मैं अपने
स्टूडेंट्स को मुझे कमेंट करता हूं कि
पहले तीन और चार साल करो
हंसी आपको अब तक दिमाग फ्रेश होना जरूरी
है टाइम प्रेशर अगर नहीं हो और साथ-साथ
मार्ग के लिए रेट सोएं तो अगर आप भी ठीक
से कर रहे हो जाएं रियली हेल्पफुल तो पहले
वह जो मैच में किन है और या नहीं सॉल्व
करो उसके बाद 125 जो भी आपको जिस पर क्रम
में सॉल्व करना है आप कर सकते हो एक बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट चीज आपको याद रखनी है कि उस
SIM सिक्सटी फाइव मिनिट्स मैं आपको आंसर्स
ट्रांसफर करने हैं आंसर शीट पर कभी-कभी
क्या होता है कि मैं लोग अपने शुरुआत में
आप अपने अ क्वेश्चन पेपर पर लिख सकते हो
पर चलें एग्जाम में आ रहा हूं होता है कि
मैं भी पेपर करेक्ट करने को और अंदर
न्यूट्रल टो ट्रांसफर ट्रांसफर चंदन आप
गलती कर सकते हो लेकिन फिर भी वे
रिक्वेस्ट आई तो ठीक है एक बार क्वेश्चन
कम्स फॉरवार्ड करो और सबसे इंपोर्टेंट है
वह जो 2 5 मिनट है वह रखो कि मैं आपके
आंसर ठीक से शांति से आंसर शीट पर
ट्रांसफर करने के लिए उसे स्पिरिटेड
पड़ेगा कि जर्मन अच्छी है तो आपको ज्यादा
कुछ करने की जरूरत नहीं है आईडिया इसकी
बाबा
में आ अपना एक क्लियर थॉट थॉट रखो कि मैं
आपको किसी इसे फोल्ड करना है और टाइम का
ख्याल रखना डाट अभी हम जाते हैं * को तो
यह वायरल बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है मुझे
खुद को बहुत पसंद है तो जैसे चैलेंज पर
अगर आप देखोगे तो चीन के बाद सबसे ज्यादा
लोग कहीं पर फेल होते हैं सबसे ज्यादा कि
अगर लोगों को डर लगता है तो यह रंग का है
कि उस प्रेसिडेंट ट्रेवल में फिर भी आप
पूरी तैयारी करके जा सकते हो यहां उस मिनट
का खेल है तो वहां पर अपका आपको शांत रहना
सबसे इंपोर्टेंट है तो सबसे पहले हम उसका
पैटर्न देख ले जाना सेंड एवं हो या सीटों
पैटर्न हमेशा सिमिलर ही रहता है कुछ
सुनाएंगे आंसर लिखना है जो थोड़े से
चेंजेस है वह अब हम भी देखते हैं तो हम इन
डिटेल देखते हैं पहला जो टाइल है वह एकदम
सिंपल है उसमें क्या होगा आपको टोटल पांच
टेक्स्ट सुनाई जाएंगी पांच टैक्स वह इधर
आपके मतलब टेलिफोन के आंसरिंग मशीन पर
होंगे या फिर आप का अनाउंसमेंट हो गया
ट्रेन स्टेशन पर यह
कि मौलवी और हर मिनट पर हर वह पांच
ट्रैक्स पर एक राइट फ्रॉम योर लक होगा
रिस्पोंस और एक एबीसी वाला क्वेश्चन होगा
ओके और आपको उसके आंसर लिख दें तो फॉर
एग्जामपल मैं आपको एक ऑप्शन में एक बताता
हूं कि वह आप हेलो मैं डॉक्टर मार्किंग
यहां से बोल रही हूं और आपके जो आज के
अपॉइंटमेंट कि वह हमको पोस्टपोन करने
पड़ती है कल तक प्याज डॉक्टर नहीं है और
आपको आपसे कुछ पैसे लाने की जरूरत नहीं है
आप लास्ट टाइम अपना कैरियर प्रकार यहां पर
भूल गई थी याद रखिए कि आपको वह लेकर जाना
है इस दिन समथिंग नहीं डाइट आपको सुनाई दे
का या दो बार सुनने देख एडवांटेज और फिर
आपको नीचे क्वेश्चन होगा कि बाबा
तो सबसे पहले तो कि वह क्या आप फिट
अपॉइंटमेंट स्पून हुई है फ्रंट यारो कोई
रेड्डी और दूसरी चीज आपको वापिस क्या लेकर
जाना है ऐसे दो नंबर सी कार को ऑन कर दे
एकदम सिंपल अभी देखिए बहुत ही डेट में
इजियर टाइम क्यों है एक तो यह आपको दो बार
सुनाई देगी ओके दूसरी चीज कि है कि आपको
एक थोड़ा सा छोटा ट्रैक्टर तो आप उस पर
फोकस कर सकते हो तीसरी इंपोर्टेंट चीज हर
टैक्स के पहले आपको 10 सेकंड मिलेंगे उस
10 सेकंड में कम से कम क्वेश्चन तो पढ़ लो
तो आपको पता है कि वह आपको क्या सुनना है
और एक बार आपने और पहले जब लिसनिंग कर रहे
हो तो समझ लो कि क्या चल रहा है और दूसरे
में अल्सर कनेक्ट कर सकते हो दूसरा जो
टाइम है वह इंट्रस्टिंग है इसमें क्या
होता है कि आपको जनरली किसी म्यूजियम की
या फिर आपके स्कूल के फर्स्ट डे पर उसकी
दूर होती है या फिर आप अगर कोई सपोर्ट
प्रोग्राम है तो उसका शेड्यूल बताया जाता
है और एक बंदा एक मोनोलॉग करता रहता है अब
मैं आपको उस पर पांच क्वेश्चन उसके आंसर
देने होते हैं तो इसमें सबसे इंपोर्टेंट
चीज किया है वह टेक्स्ट चलती रहती है और
आपके पास क्वेश्चन चलते रहते हैं तो
इंपोर्टेंट चीज क्या है अगर एक अ क्वेश्चन
नहीं समझ में आए तो टेंशन नहीं लेना उसके
साथ रहना इधर आप उस पर ऐड करेंगे तो बाकी
के भी क्वेश्चन रह जाएंगे ओन दिस इज द
बिगेस्ट मिस्टेक पीपल में डोंट नो द
क्वेश्चन नहीं आया छोड़ दो आगे चलते समझ
में आया अभी इसमें कैसे मैं आपको यह एक ही
बार सुनाई देगा इसे इंपोर्टेंट एक ही बार
सुनाई देगा पर एक अच्छी बात है कि वह होने
से पहले आपको साथ सेकंड मिलेंगे उस आठ
सेकेंड का बहुत अच्छी तरह से यूज करो जो
भी आपको कम से कम क्वेश्चन के नीचे तो
अंडर लाइक कर लूं तो आपको पता चलेगा कि
पहले व्हाट यू आर एक्सपेक्टिंग है अगर
पॉसिबल हुआ तो आंसर भी समझ लो बट कम से कम
पांच क्वेश्चन के नीचे इंटर लेकर तो यह f5
थर्ड टाइम है वह भी सिमिलर है कि वह एक
डिस्कशन चलता रहेगा और उस पर साथ क्वेश्चन
है पर इसमें
फोन नंबर 2 नेटिव लोग की वृद्धि मदर टंग
जर्मन है वह बात करते रहेंगे दूसरे से
नार्मल कन्वर्सेशन और वह चलता रहेगा और
आपको 7 क्वेश्चन है रिस्ट्रिक्शन फॉर
इसमें थोड़ा सा यह है क्योंकि ऋषि पॉज
करना है आइए प्रेम थिंग इट इज़ इंपॉर्टेंट
कि भई एक खास क्वेश्चन नहीं आए तो चलेगा
ऐसा होगा ही सारे क्वेश्चंस सारे वर्ड
नहीं समझ में आयेंगे डोंट वरी नहीं समझ
में आया आगे चलो और नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन देखो
मेड थिस वेरी वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट अदरवाइज यह
क्या होता लोग पुलिस एक्शन छोड़ देते नहीं
एक नहीं आया ना बाद में देखेंगे नेक्स्ट
जरूर सिंपल है एक कन्वर्सेशन चलता रहेगा
उस पर साथ क्वेश्चन राइट या रांग लिखना है
तो अभी जब यह खत्म हो जाएगा हमारे लिए
अपने फोर्थ पहले को और जब फोर्थ चैनल को
आए वह तो कॉन्फिडेंस किसी अवार्ड बेस्ट है
यह जो आवाज है यह अपने को मतलब यह अपने
मार्क हैं तो इसमें क्या होता है देखो यह
डिस्कशन हो गए थे मॉडरेटर होता है और दो
प्रसन्न होते एक चीज के पर्व होता है किसी
चीज की अगेंस्ट होता है फॉर एग्जांपल होता
है कि मैं बच्चों को मतलब व किंडरगार्टन
है कि डिपो में भेजना चाहिए नहीं तो एक
बंदा एक साइड से बोलता है इस दूसरी साइड
से बोलता है और आपको क्या करना होता है कि
नीचे स्टेटमेंट होते हैं उसमें से किसने
बोलिंग वॉटर ने बोले इस पर चलने बोल दिया
उस पर्सन ने बोली नहीं आपको क्लिक करना है
बहुत सिंपल है और यहां पर आपके लिए बहुत
सारी चीजें हैं जो आपके साइड से है एक तो
आपको साइड से कंधे मिलते हैं वह पढ़ लेने
को कि वह यह क्या है दूसरी चीज़ों दो बार
सुनाते हैं दो बार सुनाते हैं तो उसमें आप
आराम से यह कट पहली चीज मैं आप अंदर चेंज
कर सकते कि वे कहां पर चल रहे हैं और
दूसरे में कट कर सकते
ए प्लस यॉर्क थोड़ी सी चीज है जो आपको
हेल्प कर सकती है पहली चीज तो मतलब कि अ 3
लोग है उसमें से जनरली एक आदमी दो लेडिस
है वह इस अवस्था होता है तो जो दूसरा है
उसका तो आपको यह पता चलेगा आज फिर लोगों
के जो आवाज में फर्क है वह आप याद कर सकते
हो दूसरा जो मैं ज्यादा रेस्ट नहीं करता
पर आप लॉजिकली भी समझ सकते हो रही ये अगर
किसी ने बोला कि वहीं बच्चों को
किंडरगार्टन में रखना उन पर अन्य हैं तो
जनरली अगेंस्ट वाला ही बोला गैरवाजिब कि
आगे मैं नहीं बोल रहा हूं कि यह कैसे
लॉजिकल स्पीच ओं बट यह तुम आप फिट कैन
हेल्प यू ऐिदर साइड दो बार सुनाया जाएगा
और आपको सिर्फ सेंटेंस मैच करना है इट्स
वेरी वेरी इजी यह आपके होंठ मार्क है
इंपोर्टेंट है कि तब कुछ हो जनरल क्या
होता है सेकंड थोड़ा-थोड़ा हाल गए इसलिए
लोग थोड़े टेंशन में आ जाते हैं और फिर
फोर्थ मुझे स्कोरिंग है वह भूल जाते हैं
कुछ समझ में इजी है अभी थोड़े से टिप्स
देखते हैं तो सबसे पहला टिप यह है कि अपने
एग्जाम से पहले एग्जाम से पहले क्या कर
सकते हो जितना सुन सकते हो सुनो सबसे
ज्यादा लोगों के मुझे बोलते मैंने छह
महीने एक साल जर्मन की पढ़ाई की पर फिर भी
मैं कोई वर्णन नहीं आता वह तुमने श्योरन
किया दैट इज इंपोर्टेंट मेहनत मैं अपने
लेक्चर में हमेशा बोलता हूं क्योंकि तुमने
कितना भी क्रिकेट खेला तो फकीर तो नहीं
आएगा फिर वैज्ञानिक यह किन सीखना पड़ेगा
तो हम सुनने की प्रैक्टिस पर उदासी चैलेंज
सुनो आपको जो चाहिए वह कार्टून जर्मन में
सुनो वो पर जब आप एग्जाम देने को जा रहे
हो तो आपके कानों को जर्मन सुनने की आदत
होनी चाहिए दलित महिला ज्यादा कुछ करने की
जरूरत नहीं है एक दूसरा पेपर जैसे मैंने
बोला बजे की वेबसाइट पर मिलेगा सॉल्व किया
तो बस है redmi समझने के लिए उपयोग करने
की जरूरत नहीं जनरली आपकी जो लहसुन की वह
बना रही है उसका यह सबसे अच्छा होता है
अगर अपने लेखन के लिए तैयारी की है तो
प्योर रन के लिए ओके है
ए पप्पु ज्यादा कुछ करने की जरूरत नहीं है
यौवन की प्रैक्टिस करना इंपोर्टेंट है
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट कि ड्यूरिंग हिस आफ
क्योंकि वह उस टाइम का खेल है तो सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट है शास्त्र सिंपल जा रही है
ग्राम इसलिए ज्यादा कुछ नहीं होना हट जा
रही है इसलिए एकदम नाराज नहीं होना वन
क्वेश्चन है टाइम है स्पेशली सेकंड और
थर्ड टाइम में एक क्वेश्चन नहीं आया दो
क्वेश्चन है छोड़ दो बाकी के देखेंगे हम
डोर एंड आपको 30 में से 18 चाहिए रेट ऐसे
मत करो कि पूरा शहर ही मैंने सॉल्व नहीं
किया उस अंधेरे के साथ रहो उस कन्वर्शन
केयर कंवर्ट चक्र ऑप्शन के साथ रन को आगे
इन पहला और चौथा आपके स्कोरिंग पॉइंट्स है
उसका फायदा करो दोबारा घर सुनाया है तो
दोनों बार शांति से सुनो पहली बार में
करेक्टर ऐसे छोड़ो मत दो सेकंड वर्ग उसको
अपने शांति से सुनो दूसरे चीज क्या यह
आपको 10 सेकंट सेकंड मिले उसका फायदा करके
लोग जज्बा
पॉसिबल है आ सुनने से पहले कम से कम
क्वेश्चन तो पढ़ कर लें तो उससे बहुत
फायदा होता है ट्यून ओ कि आपको कहां पर
कौन से फ्रेंड करना है ऐसे सेंट इट्स
इनवेस्टमेंट सिंपल और देखो मुझे खुद
व्यक्तियों पसंद है क्योंकि आयोडीन सर
चैलेंज 4u वहां का खेल खराब युवक को इंजॉय
करोगे ना तो यह विल ऑलवेज अट डू इट वेल
अगर आप टेंशन में जाओगे कि कैसे होगा तो
उधर टेंशन उल्टे क्लब प्रेसिडेंट तो एंजॉय
करो यह ऑरेंज ने बोला एवं हुए सीटू बेसिक
फॉर्मेट से नहीं रहेगा एवं में सिर्फ ऐसे
होगा कि वही गाड़ी नंबर 17 प्लेटफार्म
नंबर 18 की जगह 19 के आ रही है और सीटों
को जब मेरा था तो मुझे था कि वे मजबूरन जो
का काम करना बंद होता है और दिमाग कब काम
करना शुरू होता है दशरथ वोकैबलरी का यह
बदलता है तो डोंट वरी मजबूरन जितना पहले
और की प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो इतनी करके जाओ
अगर आपको नार्मल जो चल रहा है
युक्त नार्मल कार्टून समझ सकते हैं अगर आप
नार्मल जो आज छोटे-छोटे हैं आज न्यूज़
चैनल में जो डॉयचे वेले को वगैरह आता है
छोटे जरूर क्योंकि कल सब समझ कर ले सकते
हो तो आपको ज्यादा कुछ अलग करने की जरूरत
नहीं है यूरिन इज दैट वेब वेरी वेरी सिंपल
ओके इंपोर्टेंट है कि उस टाइम शांत रहना
वन क्वेश्चन अ टाइम फॉर स्टाफ और तक ने
स्कोरिंग और टाइल्स है वहां पर फोकस के
साथ हैं और सेकेंड और थर्ड में डोंट यू सर
ने लैटर डोंट नो द तरह से मुझे आशा है कि
आपको लेखन और यूरिन दोनों भी ठीक से समझ
में आए होंगे नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में हम फ्राई
बंद देखेंगे हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड
में धन्यवाद